[Music]
in creating chaos news submitted by
South Africa loves Jacob I'm troubled by
this me too a baggage handler was jailed
after swapping the destination tags on
286 pieces of lunch be a dick Wow 286 if
I was hired as a baggage handler at 8
years old this is exactly what I was
done 15 it sounds like you would have
taken the bags but why do it at all at
all that's [ __ ] up
we have question that's [ __ ]
tenacious man that's like capron with
mail that is that of is that a federal
offense it should be a federal Danny
used to be but then now it's like USPS
like now not government-owned so is it
not it never was I think it's heavily
subsidized ok so the thing is so Ida's
job at the Changi Airport thank you
sorry she whines but a janky Airport
tanga I don't know positive in China uh
uh so it's so you tampered with the bags
of Singapore Airlines and silk air I
don't know silk airlines
I flew Singapore Airlines it's the best
I was a top three Oh
what Airport did you fly into [ __ ]
Denpasar Denpasar then that was uh like
a Filipino actor oh my god dusty on the
exit by Barry alright so this man's
address so he's a baggage handler and he
was responsible for a lining checked in
luggage bags and ensuring that they were
properly placed on an x-ray machine for
security screening before they were
loaded into the planes so this x-ray
machine where he was working at it
malfunctioned so he was no longer able
to use it so he had to walk about 6
meters away so it's a about 20 feet away
for him to use this other x-ray machine
which is just right there like I'm
laying back it's so it's not far
it's like from like here to here yes and
then so like doing that back and forth
he was saying I am a tire you think I'm
so bored oh my god she was saying that
it was just like it was a lot of added
effort that if they would just fix the
x-ray machine it would make his job a
lot easier and so we found the workflow
solution
so he literally just threw a fit he
threw a fit so he because he complained
about this x-ray machine and nothing was
being done he decided to take out his
frustrations on this airline yeah and
the customers and so that's when he
started switching like swapping the
luggage bag tags and that's where they
were sitting
they were being sent to multiple
destinations all over the world that
makes sense let me get my own self in
trouble because you won't fix it he
couldn't swap all the K Cups and the
other things you could have done yeah
exactly evil things you can swap my
luggage I have my own Hello Kitty
address thing on there so it's going to
the right places I I'm coming home
that's a bulletproof Kitty address you
married him I know I did I'm [ __ ]
twisted too
yeah so he ended up making the airlines
spend about thirty thousand dollars on
compensating like pay out that that was
his goal to 221 passengers that were
affected and so the prosecution ended up
sentencing him to twenty days in jail
yeah 37 cm to death I mean could you
imagine how pissed you gotta be to know
that your asses and you're fired after
this I like one or two like thank you it
was like 286 cuz if I was the judge I
would put this [ __ ] in luggage
and ship him to all the countries he mix
it up that you'd be in the back of a
plane you had a conveyor belt and just
gonna get tossed around you think about
it that's not that much compensation for
280 bags that's a 30 grand
that's pretty low yeah it was 42,000
Singapore monies it's a Singapore my
niece
I got a thing for dollars like will you
be paying in Singapore monies today with
single pesos I think single pays all
somebody corrected us find the answer I
love single pieces what you came here
for a fact
did you really say Singapore babies oh
nice I like my knees huh - give me on to
Singapore - thank you and I won't ask
for it - right he even says it on their
bills Singapore money money
oh yeah so Hugh is just feeling very
aggrieved and ill treated by the company
I don't want to sabotage the company -
if they're pissing me off
yeah but [ __ ] all the people but two
hundred and eighty six packs how much
time did that take though that's not my
style in a three month oh thanks Dana
what the [ __ ] yeah it's just the time
and then I was thinking like how do you
switch it if don't they like steel like
they [ __ ] yeah they do it for you
don't that so I'm like how did he do
that he was like love and they have to
reprint it
I like repayment like let you go like
Mississippi by the time he takes the
tape off and then Bri puts it on it's
like you build a barn with a bucket so
nobody said it I feel like okay this one
now
that's like I'm a Disney employee I'm
pissed at Disney and so at Disneyland
and so I'm like oh you know what I'm
gonna do
I mean oh come right this way it's fast
pass line and then to my friend Mike
pretty [ __ ] wedding it doesn't do
anything to the [ __ ] management you
and dick of the year Congrats management
meanwhile doesn't everything they
normally do no idea nobody knows nobody
cares
yes that's why there's fight at certain
places like somebody thought they were
being funny and then somebody caught on
and they were like oh you want to put me
in the Fastpass line that doesn't take
say
can you slash the tires of a airplane
yeah you get on to the runway happens
all the time they'll lock those things
up how do you know well people get
people get pissed because the airline
parked next to them and yeah you know
they're taking their own hands
I saw this video of a catering truck
just going in [ __ ] circles like that
and there was no driver in it and
everyone was freaking out right and it
was getting closer to a plane dude no no
on a video and a dude came by and one of
those go-kart things and just [ __ ]
slammed it and [ __ ] got it out of the
way and flipped it over it was really
close to hitting the place yeah that's a
good James Bond movie yeah she was like
she's like what did the food truck
driver say he's like hey man so I was
[ __ ] up in there yeah it just kept
going like this in circles because it oh
I saved the day it was really slow too
cuz it was like going in circles like
that was it took forever yeah it's
pretty funny though if you could watch
the video but everyone's just standing
around like they don't know what the
[ __ ] and do you see one guy like he
thinks he's gonna run up and I gonna cut
it in the car but he's like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] and here comes his little golf cart
like boom right before hits the plane I
mean but did he get out there or was he
like I'm going down with the car yeah
don't those things not have a cover on
him does he look at his wife and he's
like did he like let it go and jump out
of it no no he hit it with like the butt
of it or he calls his wife he's like
honey I don't think I'm coming home I'm
not to launch into this [ __ ] food
truck
I'm saving lives first off I would even
know how the [ __ ] that catering thing
kept going in circles it's the thing
that loads all the airplane food into
the plane yeah and it's like it's like
just like a [ __ ]
do you think that al Qaeda is watching
with binoculars like it's been tough man
we gotta [ __ ] up we are track [ __ ]
could you imagine though that's how
you're playing gets taken out yeah we
couldn't go off we can't take liftoff
because we just could I did what a game
you can truck we got hit the tire and a
geek I took a arrow you'd be out Qaeda
celebrates with high fives yeah course
yeah what is a universal famous big fist
bump Oh a fist bump that's what I heard
doing like this that must be with you
all kinda not too hard but after I
thought they disappeared now this one
clearly isn't sponsored we're not
sponsoring this I'd actually love
al-qaeda chubby there you know they were
a former friend of America do you really
want everyone okay come on we'll get
talk about Isis if you like oh good I'll
tell you what I think about those guys
no it's okay let me just continue with
this story 286 bags that went to other
places Cray was mad about this much fun
knowing Oh 20 charges of mischief and
another 266 similar charges that were
taken into consideration so this man
who's 66 years old oh hell he's 60 he
said [ __ ] you
dude you know still isn't good duck
restaurant to be working at that's what
he said he said don't bang [ __ ] your
bags yes I did it [ __ ] good job me fix
the [ __ ] machine that's right [ __ ]
damn well have had a point in life where
you just don't give a [ __ ] you do this
he's so petty and even doing this it
makes me actually like him yeah I like
him too
he was probably like you know I met him
then he did it because he actually did
it out of view from CCTV Wow this fools
calculated is [ __ ] it looks like it
gives good feet massage alright we
traced like back some of these cuz I
ended up finding baggages and then
people complain and then they had to
compensate something they end up like
retracing like where did this bag like
who touched this bag then they confront
him in the human he probably and he was
like it's about time [ __ ] he was like
damn I can't believe it took you guys
this long and stupid bastard three minds
I know I mean but three months do the
math three months 286 bags how many is
90 days so how many predict he's doing
little a day five okay so kind of like
spring 95 Monday 286 / what 36 divided
by three three months I don't know I'm
just trying to figure out how this old
man went about doing 286 back he did a
couple of days yeah I was gonna say cuz
when you hear over three months it was
like nah he just been [ __ ] long it
took for them to not fix the x-ray
machine so I think like I would have
been pissed too right and he didn't
start right away if this story was that
he only did it to like Louie Vuitton
bags that have been like this man's a
[ __ ] hero
they're pretty obnoxious you can go hey
oh yeah you can have one of those come
my way I got an address you can send
that back oh I thought gifts wasn't your
love language it's really not but I
still accept him
[Music]